hello my name is jim park and i'm one of
the r d managers at milliprasuma
today i would like to present dynamic
lifestyle imaging about urine and immune
cells using our celasic platform
here's the outline of today's
presentation
i'll start with the basics and
challenges associated with setting up
dynamic lifestyle imaging
i'll then give a brief intro to our
turnkey select platform
which enables dynamic lifestyle imaging
with any existing inverted microscopes
main part of the presentation today will
be applications demonstrating the
utility of the cellulasic system with
particular emphasis given to suspension
cells such as t lymphocytes which play
crucial role in immuno oncology
let's start with some background
information on dynamic life cell imaging
i think by now it is very well
established that lifestyle imaging
offers tremendous biological insight
over traditional static imaging due to
spatial and temporal information
for example here we are showing the
static image of t lymphocytes loaded
with the fluorescent calcium indicator
die
at this point not much inside can be
gained perhaps other than what appears
to be different level of fluorescence
among the t cells
now if we were to take time-lapse image
of these t-cells
as shown in the bottom of the slide
we start to gain deeper level of
understanding
to the spatial temporal dynamics of
these cells at single cell level
in this particular experiment t-cells
were activated with ionomycin which
causes increase in intracellular calcium
level
already couple observations can be made
which were not possible but we're just
looking at the static image in the
middle of the slide
for example we can notice that t cells
are oscillating at their calcium level
during the resting stage
and also that there is a significant
level of heterogeneity among the t cells
in terms of their causing responses upon
activation
let's play the movie itself to better
appreciate what is going on
in summary the advantages of dynamic
lifestyle imaging can be summarized in
this slide
analysis of cellular event at single
cell level
thus enabling study of population
heterogeneity
study of cellular biology as a function
of microenvironmental perturbations
for example we can study calcium
responses of t-cells before
during and after their activation
another common example would be dynamic
gas control such as cycling between
democracy and hypoxic conditions
last but not least is the time dimension
where we can now study various cellular
responses
such as morphology movement signaling
as well as a cell cell interaction
as a function of time to obtain spatial
temporal information of any given
biological system
now let's take a step back
and think about some of the challenges
in terms of building or buying a system
which will enable dynamic lifestyle
imaging
dynamic lifestyle imaging while it is a
very powerful tool has its challenges
this is an image from wikipedia and
nicely demonstrates the complexity of
such a system
these are very large and complex systems
with high price tag
requiring well trained scientists to
operate
also in all cases additional do your sub
components are required
to enable perfusion and fluid
capabilities
in order to create true dynamic imaging
system
these components such as pumps and
perfusion chambers with associated
controllers will further create
complexity and increase price
switching gears then uh let's talk about
our cylindric platform
what will be the key advantages of our
system
to start it is a true turnkey product
with integrated environmental control
system coupled to microfluidic plate
where cells will be cultured and imaged
the system controller shown in the
middle of the slide
is the size of a typical 13-inch laptop
in its x and y dimension
it is extremely portable and was built
with mobility in mind
the controller controls various
parameters such as temperature gas and
flow rate within the microfluidics plate
which is connected to the controller by
manifold
the software is very easy to use and
enables step-by-step protocol building
where each experimental step can be
built with user defined time temperature
gas and perfusion parameter such as flow
rate
let's take a look at the plate
in greater details
it has standard 96 well footprint
image in the centers show
one of our plate pre-loaded with colored
dyes to show individual layout of the
fluidics
plate has a six inlet oils on the left
side and two outlet wells on the right
side
connected to the central tissue culture
chamber area via microfluidics channel
as you can see in this cartoon for each
row
indicators of group 1 2 3 and 4
all the individual well within the group
are connected to tissue culture chamber
area via individual micro fluids
channels which are the colored lines
this enables up to four independent
experiments to be conducted per plate
when the plane is connected to the
controller unit vr manifold
media or reagent in each of the inlet
wells can be pressed down via positive
pressure
this will then move the media or reagent
from that well into the tissue culture
chamber area
and which will then will exit to the
outer wells
essentially this creates a system where
any desired media or reagent can be
precisely delivered to cells in the
chamber area at desired time
for specific duration and with specific
flow rate
since the plate can be temperature and
gas control
we now have a system that can offer
ability to control cellular micro
environment in dynamic on demand fashion
plate material is also made of gas
permeable polymer to allow dynamic gas
control
and the bottom of the plate is made of n
1.5 glass for clear imaging including
confocal applications
last thing i would like to mention is
that since these are microfluidics plate
we can also introduce specific micro
dimensional features
targeting certain applications such as
imaging of suspension cells or
maintenance of chemotactic gradient
now let's go over some of the key
applications
our system can be connected to two
independent gas outlets
so in this example we can create
normoxic and hypoxic conditions using
gas switching ability
the middle image shows fluorescent
intensity of reverse oxygen sensor rtdp
measured from one of the tissue culture
chamber within our microfluidic plate
ittp will increase fluorescence with
decreasing oxygen concentration and vice
versa
arrows indicate the time point at which
gas switching was initiated
we can see rtdp fluorescence increasing
as we put tissue chamber under hypoxic
condition
starting at t equals two hours
when we revert to nomoxy condition
at t equals 6.5 hours we can see
fluorescence start to decrease
now that we have established that our
system can create hypoxic or nomostic
microenvironment the image on the right
shows cellular responses under such
conditions by measuring expression level
of heatphone alpha which is a key
transcription factor under cellular
hypoxia
we are also measuring itdp fluorescence
as indicated by blue line
when cells are subjected to hypoxic
condition
we see the expression level of heatphone
alpha increasing as seen by the increase
in the black line and then later on as
cells are subjected to the moxie
condition we see fluorescence of rtdp
decreasing which in turn is followed
rapidly by decreased expression of
hyphen alpha
intensity of dappy is plotted as a
control in purple line
and it shows no meaningful change under
changing oxygen levels
next we would like to show you lifestyle
movies generated using biotracker
hypoxia lifestyle dye this is a cell
permeable life cell dye
which becomes fluorescent under hypoxic
condition inside of cells
here we are looking at a431 cells
loaded with and without dye after 16
hour incubation under hypoxic condition
to show its specificity
now let's take a look at the lifestyle
movie
next we'll look at the autophagosomes
formation under hypoxia
using fluorescent lysosomal marker lc3
under hypoxic condition
cellular stress will induce the
formation of punctate autophagosomes
and this can be visualized and measured
based on lifestyle imaging
let's take a look at the movie
next applications
we're looking at intracellular
trafficking of proteins
in this case
we are examining internalization of
fluorescent egf receptor upon egf
activation you will notice upon the
addition of egf the receptors start to
quality together which then gets
internalized to endosomal compartment
with characteristic punctate patterns
let's take a look at the lifestyle movie
while the migration and innovation
is widely performed on membrane
platforms
they do not allow live cell imaging for
obvious reasons
here we now show how microfluidics
can enable live cell imaging of cellular
migration
while maintaining chemotactic gradient
we have a microfluidics culture chamber
that is connected to two parallel flow
channels
cells are cultured in the middle chamber
and chemoattractant is profused into an
adjacent channel
as you can see in the images at the
bottom
cells will migrate towards the presence
of chemoattractant
let's take a look
perhaps most obvious utility of dynamic
lifestyle imaging is calcium imaging
many cell types respond to external
stimulation by increasing intracellular
calcium level often these calcium
responses are transient responses which
only last for short duration of time
bottom images of the slide show calcium
responses of hela cells to atp
and you can see that the response occurs
within a minute of atp introduction
imaging this type of rapid transient
responses require on-demand dynamic
imaging capability
now let's take a closer look at the atp
induced calcium responses
of hela cells
we will cover one more example of
calcium imaging where cells are
undergoing rapid spontaneous calcium
oscillation
immediately shows
cardiac muscle cells undergoing a
spontaneous contraction
with live cell imaging
we can better understand the temporal
dynamics of such behavior
images on the left show calcium
fluctuation of individual cells over
time
we can see that the cells are actually
beating every 2-3 seconds as seen by the
ups and downs of the costume level let's
take a closer look at the livestream
movie
next i would like to cover lifestyle
imaging of suspension cells
which pose unique challenge due to their
non-other hearing nature as you can see
on the image at the bottom left
during life cell imaging suspension
cells will move up and down making it
impossible to image cells at single cell
level
however if we introduce micron scale
ceiling that we can confine these cells
on their single focal plane and enable
clear visualization of cells during life
cell imaging
now we can use this micro sealing
feature
to examine in great detail cell cell
interaction of t cells with that of
antigen presenting b cells
let's take a closer look
here's another example where we're
examining t-cell appetopsies at single
cell level
we're using cd95 activation to induce
program cell death and then visualizing
the cellular events using caspase 3
specific apotopsies pro as well as annex
in 5.
let's take a look at the livestream
movie
i would like to close the application
part with 3d livestream imaging
we know that currently 3d tissue
culturing is very hot topic
shown on the left side are images of mcf
cells
grown in our microfluidic plate compared
to a regular chamber slide
let's take a closer look at how these
cells form 3d structures in our play
in closing out
i would like to mention some additional
features of our system
in addition to dynamic lifestyle imaging
it can be used as an automation platform
for tasks such as staining
we can also enable extraction of cells
after imaging for example tryptonite
cells can be interrogated by flow
cytometry
proteins or nucleic acid can also be
collected and analyzed as well
that covers our applications overview
now for summary i would like to quickly
go over our plate offerings
we have a number of plates targeted for
different cell types
so all our plates that start with letter
m are intended for mammalian imaging
whereas our plates with letter b and y
are intended for bacteria and east
imaging respectively
we do enjoy tremendous number of
publications many of them in top
journals further demonstrating the value
that we bring for our customers
now in summary
we know that the real in vivo biology is
complex and dynamic
an ability to perform dynamic live cell
imaging
offers unique window of opportunity to
better understand these events
with celasik we can now better control
the dynamic cellular micro environment
with turnkey offering leveraging
microfluidics
our system enables wide range of studies
which can better recapitulate complex
individual biology
with that i would like to thank everyone
if you have any questions please do not
hesitate to contact us or visit us at
www.selazy.com
thank you
you